las fuerzas ucranianas ya han estado
adelantando la contraofensiva en la
parte norte de la región de donges la
cual es técnicamente al administrar
leyes partón script bueno
administrativamente parte de donges que
es el donbass el área donde están
combatiendo no es exactamente el donbass
no es la zona minera sino los bosques
alrededor del imán un objetivo muy
importante para las fuerzas ucranianas
en el norte de la región de donges hasta
donde sé no la han tomado aún pero
aparentemente si han tomado el poblado
débil o jurista que está en la región de
lugares han descrito
este tipo de estadios el instituto para
el estudio de la guerra dice que esto
está confirmado con vídeo geolocalizado
y parece que las fuerzas ucranianas
tienen completo control de vilo jurídica
y esa es una victoria muy simbólica muy
significativa el vivirlo jurídica está
en la región de lugares y eso significa
que rusia ya no puede reclamar que tiene
control completo de la región de lugares
long decline se enfocan sólo lo que
quiere decir que la única región
ucraniana de la cual rusia puede
reclamar completo total control es
crimea es una victoria simbólica y los
soldados ucranianos con los que he
hablado en estos días parecen
entusiastas con la idea de continuar
avanzando lo más rápido en el este de
ucrania
en esto